this video is going to be sponsored by
books but more on them later so i think
if you're starting the new year after
summers and you're a student you're
probably wondering what kind of products
you need or what kind of tools you could
use such that you can optimize your
studying so i'm here to help you to show
you the products that i've used over the
last few years during my bachelor's
master's and now my phd i have really
for me optimized and increased my
studying productivity so let's get
straight into it so the first product i
want to talk about are noise cancelling
headphones and i have two of them and
that's just because one of them broke
down a while ago but then it suddenly
started doing it again and i was really
surprised about that so the first one i
bought almost five years ago i think are
these bose headphones and if you're
wondering what you should buy bose or
sony i think they're actually really
similar bose and sony um but i have to
say noise cancelling headphones for me
have been maybe one of the products i
love the most aside from my laptop of
course and that's because i study in a
lot of environments i've studied in
airplanes i've studied in trains i had
to study in busy cafes i also have
roommates and roommates of course that
talk a lot or whatever and i think
having these you can kind of study in
any environment and if you're a student
and you don't have any money i was also
in that predicament a few a while ago so
then i just used earplugs of course and
i think they're very similar but i also
love listening to music so i now have
these the sony so i upgraded from the
bose to the sony but to be honest
they're almost the same so i would just
try to buy the cheapest ones or try to
find the cheapest ones but noise
cancelling headphones have been such
lifesavers so yeah if you're
studying in a really loud environment or
you have family that's talking all the
time i would really consider buying one
of these um they have saved my life in
many situations so the next tool i want
to talk about is of course if you watch
this channel for a while is notion and i
personally love notion i think it's a
tool that i have used the most so
throughout my channel i've talked a lot
about notion but i use it for almost
anything so i use it to keep my class
notes i use it when i'm myself teaching
so i was a ta for example at nurmage a
little while ago and i made this page
such that i could remember all the notes
students had to take or which class
schedule was where and i also personally
love it for learning new skills so i'm
usually also randomly learning new
skills so something i'm working on at
the moment is to create a website and i
on this website i have many ideas what i
want to do but the first thing usually
what i start when i want to make
something new is i do this deep dive or
this research into websites i love for
example or how i want my website to look
like and i usually put all of that in
notion and notion for me then becomes
almost this research bank with
everything from topics i love in my life
but also topics that i learned at school
and i think if you're a student it's
really important to have a bank like
this that you can put all your ideas in
because as a student you will go through
life learning many things and you will
also forget many things but it's so nice
if you can look up topics that you used
to be interested in or that you're
interested in in the future and then you
can just put it all in one place and
re-remember some of the things you learn
so the next thing i really think every
student should have is an e-reader so i
have this e-reader it's a kobo and i
bought this because it's pretty cheap
and i use this almost daily so i always
have this in my bag so whenever i have a
moment between um traveling or i'm bored
at a certain point i usually grab my
e-reader and i start reading i also read
a lot on my phone and on my ipad and the
amounts of books i go through on my
e-reader are a lot so i love to buy hard
copies and soft copies as well but
sometimes i'm not really sure if i would
like a book and then i think it's a
little bit wasteful if i have all these
books lying around that i don't really
enjoy so if i'm not sure about a book i
usually first have it on my e-reader and
i think a really good challenge to take
if you have an e-reader is to try to
replace most of your phone time by
e-reading time i think if you try to do
this throughout the week you will really
see how much you actually use your phone
and if you replace this by an e-reader
how much more you read so i sometimes do
this when i notice that i'm on my phone
too much i try to challenge myself to
replace that time by using my e-reader
which brings me to today's sponsor books
they were kind enough to send me one of
their products which is the note air 2
plus so i really like this note because
it's kind of between an ipad and an
e-reader in the fact that it's still
kind for your eyes so it doesn't have a
bright screen like an ipad but you can
write on it like an ipad which i really
love so i used to read most of my papers
for example on my ipad and i also read a
lot of ebooks on my ipad because i
really love writing on the things that
i'm learning about i think if you write
whilst you're learning you actually
retain more of the information so i
usually when i read a really difficult
book for school for example i usually
put little notes or little question
marks in the margin and the thing is
although i love the ipad it is really a
screen and i think my screen time at the
moment is about 10 hours so that's what
i really like about this product because
it's still really good for your eyes and
it doesn't strain your eyes because it's
very similar to a book so right now i'm
reading a few books on this i'm reading
think like a monk i think it's really
interesting i would highly recommend it
i'm reading the comfort but book by matt
hay um this one is a bit dubious i'm not
sure if i like it too much the one thing
i do like about it is that there are a
lot of quotes in it and then i can write
little inspirational messages to myself
and the last book i'm reading is
earthlings by sayaka muhata and that
book is strange that's the only thing i
can say about that book but if you love
reading and you're also a student i do
think this is a really nice product to
have in your kit and to consider as an
alternative for the ipad so the next
tool i use a lot of which i have also
talked about is pomodoro timer so there
are a few pomodoro timers i really love
i love forest of course just because
it's super aesthetic and i kind of like
to have it on my computer for example
and just show this really aesthetically
pleasing screen but i also use promo
focus dot io and this is just it's less
aesthetically pleasing but it's free and
i find the interface a little bit more
intuitive so i usually use two types of
cycles of pomodoros or i use 25 minutes
and then five minutes rest and these are
usually for things tasks i'm really
putting off so when i have these 25
minutes i just that's just kind of to
put me into flow or to really push me to
finish something and i also use these 15
minutes 10 minutes rest and that's
usually for longer projects but i
personally really love pomodoros i don't
always use it i've talked about this
before but i think if you are doing a
little bit more flow work where you're
really getting into this flow and deep
work i think then pomodoros are not
really suitable for that i would just
try to keep on working until you get
really tired but i think if you for
example really have to cram for an exam
using pomodoros can really motivate you
and also can keep you on the task
because you're not really allowed to use
twitter for example or facebook in
between and that really allows you to
focus your mind so to say and the last
thing i want to talk about number five
is just to have a planner slash notebook
so i always carry a notebook with me
even though i have now my note air and i
have an ipad and all these electronical
devices because throughout the day i
think you get a lot of good ideas and
it's good to scribble them down
somewhere because otherwise you forget
them and of course i also record them in
the phone but some of these thoughts
require a little bit more thought or a
little bit more deep diving and then i
think it's good to just take a minute
and to really write down what you're
thinking about also something i love to
do is journal and i don't journal
consistently but i do try every day at
the end of the day or at the beginning
of the day to write three things down
that i loved about the day or that i'm
looking forward to and i think that just
kind of gives a positive mindset or a
positive way to think about your day and
i really learned this from my friend
sage um because she's been doing this
consistently for years and she does it
on her github which i think is really
cool but seeing the things she writes
down and looking back through her notes
is just really fun and it really shows a
really fun life that she's actually
having and all the experiences she's
having with her friends and her dog
charlie and that's just for me really
fun to see and i think another way i use
it is i also have this thicker planner
which i bought online somewhere for
really cheap but the thing i really love
about this planner is it has these
hour blocks and i sometimes love to
write down just a rough plan of what i'm
thinking of doing throughout the day and
i don't always do this i don't always
think it's necessary sometimes i just
want to accomplish one or two things
that i really have to focus on
throughout the day but especially if my
days are a little bit more busy i like
to plan them out such that i don't feel
as overwhelmed so these are tools i've
always used during my studying an
e-reader and laptop and my headphones
and then i'm good to go wherever i am
and i don't think you really need
anything else and if you have a product
or tool that you really love and use a
90 of your studying time i would love to
hear about it please put it down in the
comments below because i would always
like to optimize my studying and my
studying routine and otherwise i'll see
you next week bye